um but we were just talking about joe  biden and you actually  met joe biden whenever you or president  biden know when you were doing uh parks  and rec right  yeah we got the chance to go um and film  with him and it was  so fun and really really exciting  because we only had about  20 minutes to do it because he was busy  with other things um but i was so  excited about your interview with dr  biden because  like you my mom is a teacher and i'm  just so excited there's going to be a  teacher  in the white house like a current  teacher like she didn't quit her job  yeah that was the best part of the  interview for me because i everybody  always talks to me about balance because  i like to be busy  but i also think it's really important  to show your kids that you can  be a great mom and have a career and  do it all it just takes balance so it  was really cool to get to talk to her  about that about balance in general  you